welcome everybody another hangout super
excited to be here with my friend tor
who's been on the channel before tor
welcome back thanks Ivan I was so
incredibly stoked right now I feel the
energy I'm feeling energy love it ah tor
reached out to me because he's creating
the new premium course on his website
through his business about how to
connect with influencers and how to get
massive exposure from scratch from
nothing as an entrepreneur and he wanted
to include some content from me on there
and I said I love it let's do it let's
also turn it into a YouTube video so
that you guys can learn and also learn
more about what he's doing so we're
gonna pretend like this is tours show
here and he's gonna do his intro and
take over and then we're gonna get to
your questions afterwards so if you have
questions about anything we're talking
about leave it in the comments on the
side and we'll answer it later on over
to you man that's awesome okay guys I'm
so excited to be right there now with my
good friend Adam Kumar kill Evan
Carmichael he's a prodigy he managed to
like build an incredible successful
business and sell it I think it was like
19 years old and then he's just like
done like business adventure after
business adventure and obvious like the
successful Sara Sara entrepreneur behind
the very successful site Evan Carmichael
calm and yeah he has built the YouTube
channel from like almost nothing to now
is I think it's 260 thousand subscribers
in a very short amount of time this man
is the bub and I am so extremely happy
to have him here I love it man I'm
feeling the energy so what I think
people would like to know Evan is that
when you started out how did you network
with other with influencers at that time
so when I started out my first business
like I said I was 19 or like you said I
was 19 uh I didn't know anybody
I had no contacts my parents weren't
entrepreneurs I didn't have a ankle Joe
who was an entrepreneur who could help
me I was
my own and I went to talk to my banker
because I thought bankers support
entrepreneurs right so I'm gonna go talk
to my banker and see I can introduce
myself I just had a regular I have a
tiny savings account you know like I'm
gonna go and say hey how can you help me
and they were like well do you need a
loan but um I don't think so but I mean
I need help I need contacts I need to
you know try to build this thing up and
funnily enough they actually put me on
to somebody who put me on to somebody
else who put me on to somebody else and
that first person became my first kind
of business mentor and so I think it
just starts with asking I think a lot of
people don't know where to start to find
mentors and connect with people connect
with influencers connect people couldn't
have an impact on your business and it
just starts by asking is people know
other people and and a lot of times it
comes from the most random places and
people who you wouldn't expect but if
they know your story and they know you
like you trust you then as soon as
you're specific in your ass I'm looking
for somebody who can help me do this
then it gets everybody's brain thinking
about you and maybe they don't know
anybody in the moment but they they're
thinking about you during the day so if
an entrepreneur you know like a website
designer comes to me and says hey I
design websites I don't know how to grow
my business do you have any contacts web
design you know I know tons of web
designers and so why am I gonna pick you
over anybody ask them to refer business
to but if you said I'm the web designer
for the salon industry hair salons and
I'm trying to find more hair salons
immediately I'm thinking about hair
salons you're probably thinking about
hair salons now do I know who is in the
hair salon business and so like being
specific in your ask makes it easy for
people to help you and so if you know
what you're going after then just start
talking to the people who are who are
already in your network and then they
may not be like high-level people but
somebody knows somebody who knows
somebody who can help make that first
connection for you thank you I think
that's a really good
because what you actually say there is
that the more you're narrowing down your
ass the more specific you make it easier
for people to actually be thinking about
how they can help you if they're in a
position and they want to help you and
that's also kind of in the online
business world when it comes to your own
online business but it's really
important to narrow down your niche
because like if you're just doing
marketing there like a gazillion people
doing marketing once you narrow down
further and further further it's so much
easier to stand out and as you say to
actually build relationship with people
I love it so that is that is so
extremely cool I also think that what's
really important what you say is that
you don't you shouldn't be afraid to do
the ask because like if you have like if
you have the good manners and you're
just like yeah very kind of likeable a
guy or gal and it's really more about
actually in my experience and problems
yours to have and to be be interested in
other people and to generally be
interested in just connecting for the
sake of connecting and that's something
like oh I want to buy your coffee and
then you will share my link here for my
website in - hahaha relationships let me
share a couple stories that I think can
help show how I've done it and maybe
there's lessons in there for people
watching the first one when I had one of
my companies
I was I was young and I felt like I
didn't have a lot of credibility yet and
I think if you're a young entrepreneur
or someone is just getting started and
you feel like you know people look down
at you because you're young or you don't
have a lot of background experience one
of the things that I wanted to do to
give myself credibility was I created a
guide on my website I called the guide
to professional success and what I did
was I connected with a whole bunch of
well-known speakers and asked to use an
article that they had written in an
e-book that I was putting together
and so we got Brian Tracy and Zig Ziglar
and everybody who's you know in that
industry and ask them could I use your
guide to or your article that they
already written I'm not asking them hey
write me a unique article like that's a
huge extra step said hey this is great
article that you wrote I'd love to add
it to my eBook
and I started with one just randomly
wrote out to that one person and then
went to another one and went to another
one is as I got the first person then I
use their name to get the next person
and get the next person and then it's
it's something everybody wants to be
part of because all these other people
being a part of it and then I added an
article for myself as well so it was me
with Brian Tracy and Jack Canfield and
Zig Ziglar and all these guys that
instantly improved my credibility that
they were a part of it when I started my
website at Evan Carmichael calm and then
had guest contributors I wanted to get a
lot of big-name people on my website
writing and one of my goals was to get
Donald Trump at the time The Apprentice
that just came out and it was the
biggest thing on TV for entrepreneurs
everybody's watching The Apprentice we
had a princess parties happening at my
house and so I wanted to get him I gave
me one to get his content on my website
and the way I did it was I reached out
to Seth Godin and Guy Kawasaki and they
may be known they're both authors and
they're both bloggers if you're in the
marketing world you probably know who
they are if you're in the general world
you may not know who the names are and
my thought was I want to I want to get
them onboard and then pull for higher
names and so Seth I just wrote to
because I was a fan of his blog I said
Seth you don't know me my name is Evan
I'm a huge fan of your blog a lot of
your market advice has really changed my
life and it's had an impact on what I'm
doing I'd love to take some of the
content and promote it to my audience on
my site are you okay with that and he
wrote back personally from his Yahoo
okay
said yes go for it Guy Kawasaki was also
on my radar another guy another blogger
who I thought might be willing to do
this with and I was telling my friends
about it and one of my not friends just
like acquaintances that I talked to
happen to have a connection in the Guy
Kawasaki and he made that introduction
for me and guy said yes go ahead and do
it and it just came from you know when
people say hey tor how you doing and you
say yeah yeah I'm good or you might say
oh I'm awesome cuz you got the Tor
energy but a lot of times when you're
when you're meeting people and they ask
you how you are you just give a a really
BS answer like yeah I'm good things are
good things are great like you don't
want to get into anything even saying
something like yeah it's good I'm trying
to figure out how to get in touch with
Guy Kawasaki like just say that to
everybody that you're meeting and
somebody will eventually make a
connection into you that will help and
so I got guy I got Seth and then I used
their names to go out there bigger
people right I would go after Michael
Gerber who wrote the Ebro Emeth at the
time it was a big name is it wrote to
Michael and said hey you know I've got
Seth and I've got guy and I want to add
you to this list right and said I did it
again it's like the same model I did
with the e-book I did with the website
and eventually got the Trump he was
promoting his Trump University at the
time and contributing some content to
the website and there that kind of just
then the site took over right we had all
these big names on the website everybody
wanted to be a part of it and so going
after the smaller fish in the industry
where there's easier to get the access
to and then using their names to go
after slightly bigger fish until you get
to the top where they've seen all of
these people have been involved they
want to be involved as well so that
really helped me with my website and
then another quick story about my
youtube channel one of the things I keep
talking about for YouTube is you want to
make you want to do collaborations you
want to connect with people you want to
you know find someone who has a bigger
audience than you and do some kind of
collaboration together to have them
introduce you to their audience and
first off some people are way more open
to collabs than others
like I love doing collaborations my
default this video like tour wants me to
write something for his articles like
how about we do a video you can take
what I say and put that into an article
so it's my style but there are others
who are really open to collapse too and
I always start with the people who I
actually look up to who I actually
consume their stuff right I find it just
way easier because there are some people
whose stuff that you watch I give you're
watching my channel a lot then you feel
like you know me a little bit more and
you could write something more personal
more meaningful more passionate than to
somebody else and so I started with Tim
Schmoyer and Derral Eve's who are big in
the YouTube video world like how to have
a successful YouTube channel really
well-known in the industry
general public maybe not but I was
following all of their stuff taking all
of their tips and advice and applying it
to my channel and I started commenting
on their articles I started on their
videos every video I'd leave some
comments and evolve in their community
and eventually reached out to them and
said hey I have a youtube channel I'd
love to do some kind of collaboration
here are some ideas that I have in mind
for potential topics and both of them
were back and said yes and we did I've
done three I want to think I think with
Tim and one with Derral and my channel
has grown to I think be bigger than both
of theirs but they're really nice anyway
they're just in one space where mine is
a bigger topic but it was because I was
a fan of what they were doing already
that had made the connection a lot
easier and you know as an influencer in
my space I pay attention to the people
who are engaged with my stuff I pay
attention to the people who leave tons
of comments right Zeno is in the chat
right now watching you know Zeno's in on
all of the stuff that I do and of Zeno
asked me to do something to help I would
do it and so because he's a recognizable
face a name has been involved even you
like how we met you were insanely
engaged on the Twitter chats that I was
putting out and just being a force for
good and encouraging and having tons of
energy and showing up every time
and then when you asked me to be
involved in one of your tweet ups or
something you asked me to do something
like sure yeah happy to you like tore
oneself I don't even care you know you
know you think you sent me this whole
email but here are the benefits you're
gonna get like you know what I don't
care about the benefits tours asking me
to do it so I'm gonna do it because it's
tour right and that I mean we've never
met face to face
we didn't have a video interview yet at
that point it was only because of the
online engagement that you had that you
were hyper involved with and you an
important member of the community and so
like if you are a member of the
community enough the person in charge of
the community takes notice if you leave
one comment here there and you just
write like thanks to the video it's not
enough right like that's not gonna get
on my radar what if people are
constantly sharing my stuff on Twitter
or being a force for good on the YouTube
comments I notice and when they asked me
to do something if I can help them I'm
gonna do my best to do it and so it's
work like it still work right to do that
if somebody just comes up tons of people
who write in to me say hey Gavin can you
review my app you know can I send you my
product and you try it and tell
everybody about it and it's just it's
overwhelming and I'm not even that big a
name right like you go up to the bigger
guys they're just I can't imagine how
they even deal with it but if you are an
important and engaged member of the
community they will notice you and it's
much easier to get them to say yes and
then you can use their name to get other
people involved as well definitely not
so I'm so blown away every time we talk
because like I expect you to bring some
awesome tips but you're kind of over
delivering every single time there is a
reason why you are my big inspiration
because you were one of the guys that
you really kind of pushed myself to go
out of my comfort zone and just to
really over deliver and for me it's more
just like after I got to know you and I
just like yeah for like hey I haven't
he's like this awesome guy he's just
like very very focused on bringing
constantin value to his audience and I
was thinking like hey
obviously like this guy is doing
something right so yeah let's just try
to do something like some of the same
stuff that he's doing and yeah I gotta
say it works great cool man I love it I
love it
what you're really good at too is to
collaborate with other brands like Dell
which you are having this awesome
Twitter chat with now could you tell a
little bit more about some examples how
you have built the relationship and kind
of went to the corporation part because
that I think people will find helpful
yeah I think so I've worked with some of
the top brands in the world who market
entrepreneurs so Dell and Microsoft and
American Express and you know all those
guys and I think it depends on what your
strengths are I am NOT the salesman I am
NOT the knock on doors and go Network at
Advance I may seem very excited but I'm
actually an introvert like I hate going
to come and don't go to any networking
events unless I'm speaking at a
conference or something I don't go at it
I don't talk to the guy next to me on
the plane you know if you're about
entrepreneurship it's easy to get a
conversation going then like I open up
but otherwise I'm very introverted so if
my business relied on me being the
salesman
I would I would fall apart like the
business wouldn't happen luckily I'm
much better at the marketing side and so
when I was going after these big brands
every time I tried to reach out to them
I never I never got anything you know I
never had never worked for whatever
reason whenever I reached out to them I
never got anything to happen in terms of
the sale I got my first my first
corporate gig was with Xerox and I wrote
a blog post and Xerox saw it and they
paid me to fly to Florida to talk to
their executive team about the world of
you know the internet and how to sell
their entrepreneurs and then I started
working with other companies all because
they saw me as an expert in my industry
and so my business model is I try to
kick up as much
as possible I try to just help people as
much as possible and it generates
awareness and then brands want to be
part of that if you have a community
brands want to be a part of it and join
in on the community and you have to be
very selective in what you take on and
don't I turn away more deals and I
accept mostly because they want me to be
a pitchman for something like hey Evan
can you come on and tell everybody why
they need to buy you know this new
keyboard here or something right it's
like no like I will talk about products
that I use but if I don't I have to use
it and like it to talk about it and
everything else is very like the channel
is very genuine very authentic I mean I
always hear the right words but it's
like here right it's like it's coming
from the heart
and so the brands that I work with are
the ones who want to give back value to
entrepreneurs one of them is Stephen
Kelly was the CEO of sage he's got
15,000 employees they do accounting
software we do a monthly hangout on the
YouTube channel that you know people who
watches the teacher will know about it
and it's just me and him answering
questions from the audience we're not
we're not saying go by sage it's the
best Akali software ever and he doesn't
want it like if I'm if I might if I get
even if I say something good about sage
he'll like it's like well let's get back
on top I can answering questions like he
doesn't care about promoting the company
it's about providing value to the
audience because if you do that then
people will care about your company
he gets that and so a lot of people
don't a lot of brands don't so you have
to be selective with the companies that
you work with I've been so again I don't
find the pitching method works there's
tools like Fame bit that are out there
where you can connect actually a great
tool for collaborations I've done some
collaborations through famebit whether
you're youtuber or the Twitter audience
they've expanded to a couple others that
I don't because I'm not on Instagram
really I don't pay attention to that but
there's brand deals brands will say hey
for five hundred dollars we want you to
review our makeup kit and then you bid
on it
I've never had a lot of success with
those ones because the prices are too
low and you're just competing against
everybody else where when a brand finds
you and loves your audience then you
could charge a higher price and they're
already they're already kind of pre-sold
on working with you because they know
you like you trust you from watching
your stuff and so it's really just been
a marketing strategy of pumping out
awesome content and being hyper engaged
with my community and that has attracted
a lot of interest and awareness kicked
up a lot of dust and some of that dust
becomes media deals and corporate deals
with brands who want to reach my
audience
that's a cool so I don't know what they
really understand from what you're
saying and like I kind of knew this
before before he told me because I've
been kind of studying how you've been
doing stuff so it's basically just you
focusing on your tribe and you actually
just focusing on helping people and I
kind of just bringing your passion and
your genuinely kind of will to help
other people and then it's basically all
about the traction marketing because
you're attracting all the brands that
has the same values as you do you're
attracting other entrepreneurs and other
business owners that the time the same
and matters as you do and that's kind of
so much easier to cooperate when you
kind of have equal core values because
then you know that hey we're on the same
page so yeah people are kind of free so
before they reach out to you yeah I
think you just have to find like that
works for me that's my personality
I like the community side of things it
may not be for everybody like if that if
if the thought of responding to 200
comments a day is agonizing to you then
don't like it works for me but it will
not work for you so do what works for
you and this this is just and I think as
you listen to experts everybody tells
them everybody tells you what's worked
for them in the past and and you don't
want to be the next seven Carmichael you
want to be the best version of you and
and you might be able to pull something
from what
I'm saying and you might be a pull
something from the other people in your
course but you need to you know throw
away you could throw away 90% of the
things that I say and like if that 10%
like it's really applicable to you go
all-in on that and you'll see success so
like the attraction marketing yeah that
works really well for me but make sure
that that's your personality and your
style because maybe some of the other
people in the course will be able to
give better advice that I'm more
applicable to that's really awesome so
what do you do now if you if you're
networking with other influencers
because obviously you've become like a
huge influence of yourself so what do
you do now it's interesting I don't know
that I had that many proactive things
that I'm doing people will find me so
right now as an example I'm working on
two video projects with Michael Gerber
and Brian Tracy so Brian Brian and I are
gonna do a video series where we're
gonna do like ten rules for
entrepreneurs far they're gonna be on
his channel five of them I'm gonna be on
my channel and we're gonna we're gonna
link to each other let's say hey let's
see the other five go check out Brian's
channel and by Michael we're gonna do a
live interview I think on this channel
if people ask questions and learn about
him it's his 80th birthday coming up and
so it's like a big milestone for him and
wants to give back I'm sure there'll be
other things that come again I'm letting
what I found that works really best for
me is I'm focusing on the content in the
community and the other stuff happens
I'm not focusing too much of my efforts
on trying to now do the communities the
the collaboration stuff to go after
bigger people because I'm finding they
come to me and by sharing really good
stuff like as an example we did a top 10
video on 50 cent his top ten rules for
success and when my team put it out at
the start I didn't like it like ah like
half of the rules are good the other
half are just you know they're okay
you're like you know what I can't I
don't want to put my name on this like
it's got to be better and then I spent
the next 3-4 hour
personally working on this video to make
it better and we ended up spending over
eight hours just on the research side on
that plus editing plus everything else
that goes into a video in it got
released and within the week 50-cent
found it tweeted it put on his blog put
it on his Facebook and the video
exploded I didn't I don't know 50 cent
you know I don't have a personal contact
in there I don't know how it got to him
apart from like it was a really good
piece right like if I didn't put in that
extra time would it have gotten to him
and would he have shared it maybe like I
can't say that that was the reason but
maybe not like you got to be really
proud of the stuff that you're creating
and a bunch of people like Floyd
Mayweather the boxing champion shared
the one that we did all the time
a bunch of people have shared theirs and
so a lot of the connections are
happening just by creating really good
content and people wanting to be around
it on top of that I do a lot of micro
collaborations so like the Brian Tracy
one is gonna take a lot of time right we
gotta both come with our points back and
forward through view videos it's gonna
take time but it's worth it cuz he's got
a you know sizable audience and I do too
but I love the micro stuff too like I
love the live chats you know Shawn who's
you know in the live chat has watched
three different hangouts already today
asking questions and learning I love the
live stuff I love answering questions on
video right so a lot of the people I do
this live stuff with they don't really
have much of an audience yet you know
like you already have a bigger audience
and most of the people that all do these
hangouts with I just I just love doing
the live stuff and collaborating with
other people and will not come back sure
like you know if I had something to
share with your audience I'm sure it's a
hate or do you mind helping me spread
this article like something right like
it's not why I'm doing it but I know
that is there if I needed it and so it's
not just about collaborating with the
big names in this
because there's a lot of other people
too who you know this actually saves me
time as opposed to me trying to write
out our answers to your questions it
saves me time doing it this way it
provides value to the audience because
they could join in and ask questions and
be a part of it it provides more value
to you you can take this video and put
it in the course and all this other
stuff and it also builds the rapport and
relationship more than just going back
on email with some questions and so
having a collaborative approach isn't
just going higher it's also going lower
in smaller channels and smaller
audiences and you never know where that
where that will take you so a lot of the
stuff that I do I'm sure like doesn't
turn into anything and maybe their
audiences never grow but hopefully
hopefully because of the over-delivering
everybody leaves feeling like it was it
was a good investment of time and and
there's like giving more value and
you're always leaving something on the
table for them that's really good and
yeah and that's something that there I
find is so really cool about you that
you obviously because you're very busy
and are successful you're really focused
on number one to do in the medium that
you kind of feel is the easiest for you
but in addition you will be actually
leveraging your time as you say by
actually doing this live on your channel
then you need just hanging one-on-one on
skype so now we are able to basically
just reach out to more people and just
like share our message to more people
and yeah that hopefully help more people
and that's what it's really all about
just like reach as many people with a
good message and ya know so one quick
question before we start with the
questions from your audience so I just
need to ask because I think that that is
something very many people are wondering
about so when you started did you kind
of keep like a like a brief summary from
where is with your first engagement with
actually taking a Brian's contribution
and putting into your book and where you
are today with actually collaborating
with your your you
chance because that's huge it's fried
Tracy yeah so in the in the very first
collaboration so like in that ebook I
never dealt with Brian you know it's
like some low-level marketing person you
just need to get approval right like
I've made it super clear that I didn't
need anything unique I don't want I
don't need like the bigger the ass that
you're going for the harder it is to get
a yes right and so I was looking for
content I would I would try to even find
an article they already wrote and said
hey can I just republish this or would
ask them hey do you have something you
put in your newsletter or something has
already been created that I could just
share and I was dealing with like a low
level I don't remember who the person
was you just need somebody to say yes
I'm sure I'm sure Brian didn't even know
that this was happening you know he's
got a team you know he's got multiple
levels and like it's the assistant to
the marketing person who then still has
three bosses before you get to Brian but
but at the same time it's okay right
like I got Brian's name on this thing
and helped me achieve my goal and so you
don't need to go after the high you know
you have to go in at the CEO level to
really get what you're after to the
YouTube channel came about because right
now
my youtube channel is the biggest
channel for entrepreneurs on YouTube if
you look at subscribers you look at
views it's the biggest channel 4 on
traffic subscribe to so you have no idea
I want to say 265 something like there
something like that we're closing in on
300 we should hit it next month this
month maybe this month we'll see we
still got time well to 71 to 71 to hit
300 this one it'll be tight anyway Brian
plays in a different field where yes
entrepreneurs are his audience but he
deals more and like personal development
and sales and goals kind of stuff my
channel is a little bit bigger than his
but we have overlapping audience but
there's also
new audience that we both don't have and
so I was talking you know his his his I
don't know what her title is I could
look it up reached out and said we'd
love to do something with you and Brian
maybe like a ten rules for entrepreneurs
were you safe it was all her idea you
say five rules he says five bro
whenever these collabs come up I'm
pretty open I think that's part of the
key is like everybody has their own
their own thoughts and their own goals
and their own game plan and so as long
as it fits with your long-term vision
I'm I'm good with it
so Michael Gerber wants to do the live
stuff great I don't have a problem let's
do live stuff no problem Brian Tracy
wants to do live stuff but his schedules
crazy and I only you know you know I
have my stuff going on he has his and so
we're looking at a time later in the
future right now he wants to do a set
piece well he talks for five minutes and
I talk for five minutes
great let's do it you know I'm happy to
pitch ideas but if you can work with
what they already have in mind
it just works a lot easier so they saw
the size of the channel they saw an
opportunity I guess I'm pretty receptive
the guy in terms of opportunities and
collaborations and that's it so we're
working together I still haven't met
Brian personally I haven't talked to him
on the phone you know like I know I'm
higher up I guess now in the
organization that I was X number of
years ago when I did it
with Michael Gerber right now it's all
through his wife I'm dealing with his
his wife reached out to me and wanted to
do something so I'm connecting with her
we'll do the live I'll meet him there
yeah so that's the story I guess that's
really impressive stuff like I so summer
so blown away like my toupee it's almost
like blowing like off-the-charts I just
have to put it on but that was super
awesome and I really appreciate y'all so
nice that you get so now I think that's
not your audience questions cool um let
me sure one more series on my mind
it's here I'm just gonna share it one of
the things that I have so I talked about
Steven Kelly he's on my channel once a
month we do a hangout he's the CEO of
stage one of the things that I think
entrepreneurs don't do enough of it is
create a great environment around
themselves a lot of people would see a
Brian Tracy or a Michael Gerber or a
Steven Kelly or or whoever the person
that you look up to and say well they're
like way better than me I don't have
anything to offer compared to them and
when you adopt that mindset you've
already lost like it is game over you
have to feel like you can contribute
something and I remember when I first
did my first collaboration with Steven
afterwards I was in the car with my dad
and we were riding somewhere he's like
well how do you how do you get the the
guts you know to disguise a CEO with
15,000 employees right like how how are
you not nervous or worried about you
know looking bad or whatever and it's
for me it's like I don't feel I don't I
don't feel like he's better than me not
not like an ego thing but I don't feel
less and it comes from the environment
because why I created my youtube channel
or the part of the growth of the YouTube
channel has been that the top 10 series
yeah espresso series surrounding myself
with hyper successful entrepreneurs so
I've never met Steve Jobs or Bill Gates
or Walt Disney but I watched their stuff
I listen to them daily i watch the top
tens on my channel daily I still consume
every piece of content that comes out on
my channel and that creates a mindset of
greatness for me an environment of
greatness for me so I feel like I'm
surrounded by jobs and gates and all
these guys so like Stephen Kelly or
Brian Tracy or not to put them down just
like putting yourself up because if you
are approaching it like they are God and
you have nothing to contribute and
you're gonna lose every time
so there's a lot
between ego and confidence but I think
too many people are just so discouraged
they feel like they can't contribute
anything they have nothing to offer and
that prevents me from reaching out in
the first place
and it stems from having a bad
environment around you where your
environment is holding you where you are
is keeping your limiting beliefs on you
and you need to move to change like ask
yourself why why are you not why do you
not have the confidence to go and do
that and it's probably something in your
environment that's a really great guy so
let's open up for you oh yes thank you
for letting me rent okay
Kareem I have a direct email and phone
number of an influencer in the music
business I'm an aspiring producer this
person had responded to email twice in
the past seven times I messaged any tips
to get on his radar he's not a big shot
not famous but extremely well-connected
to the biggest names in music today what
advice do you have for me oh well both
did you hit at first no so first I would
do a really good research on this person
and find out like what do you think
would be the most value that you could
give to that person because in the start
it's all about just constantly being
providing value without expecting
anything in return and the higher the
influencer the more you have to give so
when I started to get knoweven I needed
to bring a lot to the table in order for
him to notice me so that's kind of what
you need to define do your research find
out what he needs and what kind of value
you can give but don't ask before we had
been giving like a lot of value in
advance yeah I mean I echoed that I love
that and for those of you who may not
know tour as well from my audience he
puts out these amazing mashups where he
connects with how many people 50 100 how
many people go in and I see to 117 it
depends it's like a hundred and
seventeen people who are influencers in
a space and have expert knowledge he'll
reach out and say hey I'm making a
mash-up of you
our best tips for marketing and you'll
contact everybody that'll all share
their tips so so I know towards any of
you and me but he's got a lot of he's
got a lot of value to share on this too
yeah so providing the value I I think
the good news is you already on the
radar like he's responded to two out of
the seven emails that you've sent he
hasn't responded to the five so what are
you sending right if you're just asking
for something then you probably haven't
provided enough value yet for him the
care and so I'd be looking at if he's a
producer does he have a channel does he
have a vlog is he on Twitter is he on
Instagram can you share her stuff what
are some of his goals can you help move
that along further can you give him
suggestions and feedback can you just
support his stuff can you give him
testimonials has you've written the book
can you leave a five-star review on
Amazon I'm like just thinking about ways
and the easiest way is to follow them on
Twitter Instagram and see what they
actually care about and then showing up
there and supporting them you know are
they gonna fight with somebody and can
you throw your support behind them that
that's how people get on my radar right
they share stuff they add value and and
then you get to the point where when you
haven't asked like went or asked me to
do this he sent me this long email like
I don't even care tour is asking me so
I'm gonna do it that's it you don't need
just tell me what the topic is can I add
value we're done
but he's provided an insane amount of
value before leading up to that
so you haven't provided enough value to
him I'd be trying to get on on his radar
a little bit more one kind of ninja
thing that I did that helped me with Tim
Schmoyer and Derral Eve's is I also made
a thank you video so these guys are
youtubers I looked at everybody who was
subscribing to their channel and I wrote
to hundreds of them each and said hey I
want to make a video thanking Tim
Schmoyer for all the insane work that he
does on his channel and a bunch of
people then made video responses that I
need I need 10 to 15 seconds of you on
camera just saying whatever message you
have for Tim these are his fans and then
I made a compilation video and it's
fifteen 20 minutes long I added my own
message hey Tim I just really super
appreciate everything that you're doing
and I collected some of your top fans we
all have different messages for you and
then just edited them all together of
all of these different Thank You cliff
some people and you can bet that made an
impact right like he saw the video he
was moved by the video he commented on
the video instantly you know he knows
who I am and so like showing
appreciation people involving their fans
so like is this guy on Twitter Instagram
can you involve some of their people and
making a thank you video compilation
just something a little bit outside the
box do but to tourist point it's all
about the value you're providing it's a
really great a better okay selves am
running a bootstrap startup should I
catch influencers in a PR firm or from
content bloggers or from startup forums
so try to stress trying to bootstrap a
business trying to find finding
fluencies to help market them look is it
from PR firms bloggers going out to
forums other places what do you think so
what I would do would actually be like
when I started my business my blog the
first time as well so I was kind of
running and on my business even though
it just started out so what I did I
picked the people in my niche which at
that time was productivity but it also
connected with other bloggers and
marketers because I just like thought
that it was a good thing to do to build
a lot of relationships so what we really
should do is like think about what is it
that you really need so if it is it PR
or is it marketing but again it comes
down to if you just build genuine
relationships and focus on actually
helping them first instead of thinking
what you can get in return like there
will be so many opportunities that will
open up you know I
I I haven't seen a single entrepreneur
have success with the PR firm yet I
think it's just their focus way more on
branding then on on actual marking for a
small business and it's and it's just
too hard to get a return like you're
paying $5,000 a month retain or whatever
it is I've never seen anybody get a
sizable return it's more for the big
companies so I don't think I think I
think the best person to be out there
talking about your business is you you
know if tours personal assistant was on
my channel saying hey good stuff
happening here and like it wasn't
passionate about it and wasn't tore and
didn't have the same advice and energy
then maybe we're not having this
conversation right now you know and so
you are the best person to tell your
story and I would start with the
influencer was a game that you feel
connected to somehow if it's a
journalist like journalists that you
actually read write vloggers that you
follow youtubers that you subscribe to
people on Twitter that you like their
stuff right that's the ones you'll have
the most immediate connection with and
you can tell personal stories around and
you're doing and you don't mind getting
engaged and reaching out to them well I
think a lot of the typical advice is
okay identify the top 100 people on
YouTube and go reach out to them and get
their advice where that's everybody
right and your pitch is boring I get
pitches all the time that are just
insanely boring you haven't watched a
single one of my videos you're writing
to me because I'm on some list somewhere
as a top youtuber and that's it I'm not
you're gonna get a yes from me
so much better to have it people who
you're you're connected to somehow and I
would be looking you could look offline
and online so like the options you get
with PR firm content bloggers or startup
forums I think it depends on your skill
set more I would suck at events like if
it's go to this event for entrepreneurs
and meet as many people as you can and
talk about you know what you're doing
that would just I would die I would
rather like I would rather
I'd rather do a lot of things and do
that in the future but but some people
like Alex who have hired to run my dance
business that's him man like you put in
him or you put him in a room and he'll
just make friends with everybody
instantly he's got that personality but
but I would not want to have him writing
content for a website like it's just
just a different skill set so can it
work yeah both of them can work it's
much more about finding what you are
naturally good at and want to get better
at and where you can get more results so
I look at I look at both potentially
sean is writing if you don't learn
something in school and you later find
you need this for your business what do
you do well it's important like what you
don't learn about connecting with
influencers in school so you know
there's a whole bunch of stuff about
connecting people and running the
business that you don't learn in school
what what advice do you have for them or
for Sean and for the people watching yes
I would say that many of the most
important skill sets as a business owner
if you want to run a successful business
you don't learn this in the school that
basically be like how to network with
people how to France how to diplomacy
and a lot of stuff and how to just like
really create a good and vibrant
community so most of the things you
don't learn in school but what I would
do without you more about it be thinking
about my find out the people that you
admire for instance like I'm Carmichael
and the other huge influencers and it
kind of just the follow them and let
their values and they're also nice kind
of rub off to you because what you need
to do the Stars we need to find people
who you admire and people who are
successful people who have already
achieved what do you want to achieve
then you need to kind of follow them and
find out what the heck did they do and
then you need to try to emulate and
replicate kind of the the steps that
they took yeah I mean I
Cotto's advice I will I didn't learn
anything really in school about being an
entrepreneur I went to university
University of Toronto which is you know
the most prestigious university in
Canada and one of them in North America
and I took a business program they had
one course for entrepreneurship in
fourth year when I'm graduating and it
was a just a just a joke like I was
already running my company at the time
and the stuff that they taught you was
just so basic and does not prepare you
to be an entrepreneur really does not
now there may be other universities or
the schools with better programs I think
two things I think one go work for
somebody who you look up to and want to
be like so you want to start a graphic
design company go work for a graphic
design guy or girl who has ten employees
who you want to emulate and learn from
them and don't just take on one project
you try to get as close to the founder
as possible work your face off
no entrepreneur is gonna tell you no you
know I don't need you to do more I don't
need you to step up and take on more
responsibilities for free you know like
you're there to learn right so you're
getting paid your salary but you're
you're basically getting paid to learn
instead of you paying to go to another
school to learn about entrepreneurship
you're getting your degree while also
getting paid to do it
second I would I would echo towards
advice and finding people who've done
what you want to do and learn from them
so there's a lot on my channel if it's
about entrepreneurship this is a reason
why this channel is the most popular
trying to entrepreneur is a lot of
putting a content on here so you can
subscribe and check that out if you want
to learn about influencers right now how
to connect with influencers you can
check out tours course that's coming out
when's it coming out to her it said yeah
it's an opening I all putting the car on
Monday on Monday so there you go the
links in the description there's a lot
of free content there's a lot of paid
content I think you got to find the
people that you connect with best from a
shared values point of view so not just
the the the content they're providing
the advice but the the values
so like if you really like tor and his
energy and his vibe then you would
probably really like the course that
he's putting out if you look at Oregon
that guy no but they keep will see me
right and some of them love the stuff
and it's great and they'll buy my book
when it comes out and others they don't
like me and that's okay like if you're
not getting the advice for me then go
get it from somebody else as long as you
you're getting the advice and you have
mentors to look up to
Jada's writing in I'd like to know the
best way to make someone remember you if
it's your first time meeting them it's
this a face-to-face meeting or is it in
a witch setting didn't specify so take
it however you want okay so anything
that I would probably mean that it would
be face to face so let's say it's face
to face so what's the best way to kind
of stand out I would say the best way to
stand out you like you is your best she
says come with the face to face yeah
okay also so let's say that this is
probably in some kind of networking
setting since you're bringing this
question up so it could probably be like
in some kind of setting where we need
other people that you might connect with
and do business with so my number one
tip would be dress like you mean
business
so dress like you if you could look at
yourself look in the mirror and you can
say like wow I really look good today
that is a person that I want to do
business with we need to kind of look
like you're professional and that you're
serious about your business then when
you meet people you need to be very
specific about your pitch so the pitch
that you use normally might be not the
best fit or the best pitch in that
specific setting so you might need to
make the pitch more adaptable to adapted
to become better so for instance when I
network with people online it's
different than when I network with them
face to face so when I want to Oslo the
capital of Norway we have a networking
meeting there when I meet people there
and I have my pitch it's very simple
it's just like a help on
our health entrepreneurs to position
their brand so you can attract the right
clients that's it it's very simple so
you need to make your pitch very simple
and it needs to kind of just provide
exactly the value that you can give for
the other person that in addition to
just like genuinely care about the other
person just like more hope is about
listening and asking questions because
you want to get to know the other person
that will kind of make the conversation
go and yeah you will definitely sell out
Jayda for me it's just all about energy
like bring the passion bring the fire be
excited listen to them being genuinely
curious about what they're doing most
people don't have a lot of passion and
excitement like if you're white at or
stand out when he was on my Twitter
check because the dude brought insane
passion energy you listen go back on the
last hundred hangouts that I've done and
look at the the first thing that people
say and look at tour and how he started
like I'm so excited to be here or
whatever it's like the energy is out the
charts and that makes it memorable right
and so it doesn't mean you have to be
like you not trying to be someone who
you're not and try to be you know the
super extroverted person but you can be
passionate and excited about something
and listening to either the person and
vibing off of that like as soon as
somebody tells you that they're an
entrepreneur it's over like I can end up
talk to them for hours and hours and it
just the time disappears because I'm I'm
just so curious about what they're doing
and how I want to provide help I want to
provide the value I want them to do well
I want to help them break free of
whatever limiting mindsets they have is
just like it's I need to do it and
they'll and I'll forget to go to the
bathroom and forget to eat and you know
it's just like the passion is there and
I don't see the wrong words sometimes
right it's not about like you've what
words do I use to open up doesn't matter
if the words you use it's the intent and
the passionate energy behind it and you
go to most networking events
most meetings most people don't have
much energy at all and so if you're the
one person who does that makes you
memorable if you're excited about what
you're doing and that shows that makes
you memorable so I try to carry that
through whether it's face to face
whether it's online and Twitter Facebook
YouTube whatever and part of it is just
thinking like am i excited to be here
and and like actually being excited to
be there you can you can get excited
about something because yeah if you're
not if you're bored then you're not
gonna you're not gonna make a great
impression Olaf influencer quite biased
sometimes I can learn from influencers
billionaires or peasants no better or
minor thinking there what do you think
if I've learned how I could spread my
word myself I think is you saying like
influencer just because your billionaire
does that make you an influencer and I
can learn from anybody yeah I think
there's a difference there so number one
yes you could learn from anybody like
for all we know perhaps the most kind of
deep the person who is best at
connecting with people might be like
this a monk in Tibet that no one knows
about but when it comes to influencer
it's basically just a term for a person
who has a large following or has the
ability to actually influence a lot of
people with what they're saying so for
instance Oprah is a huge influencer but
she's reaching a lot of people a lot of
people are respecting her and admiring
her and at least she says something for
instance stop buying this handbag
because they are mistreating animals or
whatever people will stop doing that so
yes you can definitely learn stuff from
people who are not influencers
absolutely yeah I know it's I would
separate influencer from mentor I think
maybe that's the source of the confusion
influencers more marketing term where if
you are trying to sell your product or
service you want to connect with people
who have a large audience who can
influence that for you so in the old
days it might be like a newspaper
reporter who has a following and you
know if they write a good review about
your product you're gonna get a lot of
sales you appear on Shark Tank you're
getting a lot of sales now it's moved
along a lot online to youtubers
instagramers they're not necessarily
people you look to for advice so that
they could be but it's more these people
can influence the buying decision of
many people in an industry right so
that's much more like I want to get with
an influencer so that they can promote
my product and help me get sales a
mentor somebody who you look up to for
advice on a whole bunch of topics oh I
agree you can learn something from a
billionaire you can learn something from
a peasant you're learning different
things like a billionaire can teach you
how to make a billion dollars if that's
your goal a peasant can't you know I
look at I look at you know my life
believe came from my parents my parents
always used to tell me that I'm a cost
really Carmichael and I could do
anything and that's the biggest core
value that I have when I took it from
them and so I learned a lot from them
but they're not they're not successful
entrepreneurs they're not business
people and so when I go to them for
advice it's about different issues I
still learn an insane amount from my
parents but I'm not learning the
business marketing stuff from them or
learning that from other people and so
that's what I said before about you want
to you don't want to be the next seven
Carmichael you want to be the best you
and take bits from all these people from
your parents from peasants from
billionaires and then make that the best
version of you so I think hopefully
separating influencer from mentor helps
make that distinction a little easier I
just want to throw in something at the
end that's a really good distinction in
there Ellen and one more thing you can
also find people who is an influencer
and a mentor like oh my go hey yeah it's
true sometimes it'll realize they don't
have to get
you don't have to be different okay the
bulgarian vlogger my business is my
youtube channel i'm trying to grow it
how can I start I'm from a small country
and don't have connections to
collaborate with other youtubers yeah so
this is more a question for you Evan but
I can try to answer it as well so number
one I would just start to think like
number one what type of niche are you in
what are you talking about this business
or is it quite music or you need to kind
of narrow down your niche so you know
like what you're going to provide of
value and who your target audience is
then I would basically just like find
out who the other youtubers are out
there within the same niche and then I
would as Ivan has told told before just
providing awesome value to those guys
just like be there and give them
comments watch their YouTube stuff and
all that kind of stuff so just like
stand out but you need to be genuine as
I mean don't say are great with your
hands final advice you need to kind of
be there and show up consistently
because that will make you stand out and
yeah in a good relationship in the long
run you know and I wouldn't hold the
beam from a small country against you I
think too many people do that you come
up with her the reason why you haven't
done collaborations is not because
you're from Bulgaria there are more
people in Bulgaria than in nowhere
anyway so where are you from tour yeah I
live in Norway so we have about 6
million people so money I mean and I'm
from Canada and I've never done one of
these things with a with a youtuber in
Canada have I I don't think so I can't
think of one at least in my city like
it's never face-to-face you could do an
insane amount of stuff online just find
the people who have similar interests to
you like everything that I put on my
channel has to have some kind of
entrepreneurship angle to it right it
was not entrepreneurship it was a dating
advice channel yeah
I'm married I don't have dating advice
yes correct answer my friend so like
whatever you talk about on your channel
there's there's a lot of people who have
the same they're doing the same things
those are the people you can collaborate
with and all the stuff that I've done
again my strengths has been in marketing
not in sales and so I don't go to
networking events too many people but
that's how I've had success right so you
can reach out to people you can make
connections you can comment other
people's channels you can create
collaborative opportunities with people
who like the same things as you without
having to be next to each other has
nothing to do with the fact that you're
from Bulgaria Torben I'm building an app
to avoid distraction do you have any
systems to find people in your specific
area like influencers and advisers so to
try to build an app around distraction
and procrastination I guess how do you
find influencers to help with that yeah
so that means that you're most likely in
the productivity niche which I have some
experience from before listen what I
would do I would just like it sounds
kind of silly but I would just basically
google it just google it productivity
blogs and productivity people and just
like go from there and yeah that's this
is way to find people in the
productivity image and we charted out
yeah I mean first off you're talking to
two of them right here yeah I've made a
lot of videos on time management and
procrastination and tour runs the time
management chef calm so you got to here
I think the next thing is so you build
your list you can find the list by doing
a search in YouTube for for people who
are reading about this right look at us
doing a search in Google for blogs again
I would start with people though who who
you have some kind if you like time
management right if you don't like time
management the Weizmann yeah you like
time management for some reason you like
procrastination for some reason
where did you learn the stuff that you
know from who do you gravitate towards
who have you looked up to right to make
this app whose theories of time
management have you created or leverage
to make your app or if it's a mix that's
your own like mashup right like tor has
his own version but it's pulled from
other people to it like it's the best
version for him that he wants to explain
so you know the theory behind the app
where does it come from and those are
gonna be some of the best people to
reach out to as a starting place because
again there's some kind of personal
connection but otherwise you make a list
and you start reaching out I would say
you got to reach out with like what's so
different about this app around
procrastination and using that in your
in your reach it like this is
opportunity right now when you're saying
hey here's what I'm doing why is yours
better or different or you know
interesting compared to the other apps
in a short sentence or two so that I get
the pique my curiosity I got one extra
tip there what you could do if you can
find the other apps out there the top
apps that people know about and within
the same niche that is good and you need
to find a sense s how you kind of how
your app is factored no just go and look
at the reviews of their apps that are
you're competing with and then you can
perhaps just like google it as well and
you can reach out to the people who had
already written a review of your
competitors say yeah okay listen I saw
you review about the ABC listen my app
is much better on these areas you might
be interested in tested up cool listen
guys you spent a ton of time together
and we were supposed to be on for half
an hour or already over an hour here you
never know what happens when tour comes
on I tour I know you got to go to any
kind of final message I've heard we've
linked up your your website in the end
the course that you're launching in the
description anything quick you want to
leave the audience with we basically say
that I think that silver bullet and now
I'm like completely honest I think the
silver bullet when it comes to building
your brand fast
kind of getting your business up and
running is actually be able to connect
with the right influencers make it work
you just want to use something very
simple so number one when it comes to if
you have an online business most people
want traffic to the website but the
reason why you want traffic is because
you want subscribers on your email list
but you don't really need subscribers
what if I told you that you could
connect with big influencers and build
genuine relationship as friends and they
would have a large audience then you can
basically sell an awesome product to
dare list and you can split it 50/50
that is not so much easier if you think
big very big so yeah I couldn't
connecting with the right influencers in
a genuine way and focus on helping them
out will definitely make make you stand
out and make maybe they make you could
break it in your business I love it well
thank you tor for the time thank you
guys for watching
toriel I'm looking forward to this
course and yeah
thank you guys have a great end of the
week and we'll talk to you soon